I don't care how old I get I love  bubbles over 1 million people were blown  away by time moving this smoke-filled  bubble through the other bubbles but how  does he pull it off without making  anything go pop if I was to just touch  it without making any adjustments he  would make a hole in the surface which  due to the surface tension would rip the  bubble open and it would pop to prevent  this tie is cool a design with the same  soap mixture he used to make the bubbles  this gives the water molecules in the  bubble film something similar to stick  to so the whole seals up around his hand  the bubble rearranges itself using his  hand as a wall and this reduces surface  tension so using his wet hand he can  reach in take hold the smoke-filled  bubble and he's then able to pull it out  of the other bubbles and become a bubble  Hiro Babu  [Music]  you